welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a friend
the podcast that gives and never takes
just made that up doesn't really make
sense joined as always
by my Chums my pals my Amigos my
Compadres okay my uh compatriots my
comrades as part of the late 1970s
Brezhnev era Soviet Union of course uh
Sona good to see you good to see you and
uh Matt Corley Hi boss how are you do
you really think of me as your boss
because you never act like it oh well
you never act like my boss no I'm
completely yeah irresponsible boob yeah
I don't think we do have that I don't
think we have that Dynamic where uh
anyone
fears me or shows respect well there is
like a bullying side of you that's kind
of like an old school boss oh please we
all know that's a character no and the
real me oh you know it's funny I did
have someone on the street who's a big
fan of the podcast come up to me and
they said they really love the podcasts
and then they said are you really mad at
Gorly and I said no I'm not he's he's
great and they went oh it's really funny
but and boy does he really gets you
going and I was like I I so I wanted you
to know that
people see what's really happening
people see what's really happening that
the world knows I want you to know that
thank you the world sees me uh for the
Tyrant that I am yeah that's how you
feel like a boss I guess like oh boss is
here what's he gonna be like or Daddy's
here I just don't want to be the butt of
a lot of jokes yeah that's it no you
would never you're not the butt of jokes
I'm uh all right I'm sorry I'm I didn't
have my glasses on oh yeah oh my gosh
I'm so sorry yeah I oh I didn't see you
I thought you were Indira Gandhi revered
I didn't say that you were a son of
Mustang oh yeah yeah no no no no people
don't make jokes about in turkani but
yes you yeah no you I I fear you in the
sense of I don't want to ever trigger
something that makes you do a whole bit
and then the whole room is laughing at
me and then you make me high-five you
because that is so humiliating there's a
genius thing that I came up with which
is uh and I I should get you know if
people are getting Nobel prizes for
creating fission or Fusion I think I
should get a Nobel prize for the fact
that I will get a whole room
um laughing at my bit about Sona while
she's there and then I'll put my hand up
for a high five and she
has to give the high five she just does
why do you do it you have to you would
do it too you just do because when
people are laughing that hard and you
put up a hand for a high five it's
there's this flow of energy that you
have to go along with you're like in a
little kayak and you're being rocketed
at 180 miles an hour and I anyone on
staff when I put that hand up and the
whole room is laughing at them they put
their hand up for the high five this is
just like people being complicit to
tyrants in history you you think you
would never do it but you can't ever
exactly until you're in them yes yes and
this is really I'm glad you agree with
this the reason I the reason I do it is
to teach people that this is how tyrants
get away with what they get away with
this is my way of you're educating
people there you go no I think you're a
sick person yeah I've had I've been
educated by many very sick people yeah a
lot of teachers are sick uh you know
tyrants in their own way do you think
you're a normal boss oh God no yeah it's
a mess so you take take responsibility
for this yeah I mean as long as there
are no consequences I take full
responsibility would you ever do
Undercover Boss
oh I think people that's a great idea
I've watched that show Undercover Boss I
think people would know it would be
impossible well I don't see how you
disguise me and not know it's me because
it's it is like you take Sesame Street's
Big Bird and you put glasses on him in a
mustache people are gonna and then he
he's under he's Undercover Boss at
Sesame Street people are like oh my God
Big Bird what are you doing that's what
it would be like you'd have to do like
down on your knees with shoes at your
knees like dwarf like dwarf on golf yeah
right yeah Tim Conway's invention yes I
would do that I would have to do
something radical yeah or have radical
Facial Surgery
um that's permanent
but it would be fun to go on Undercover
Boss what would people say about me if I
came in and you didn't recognize me and
my name was Otto
Otto
um from and I and but I was raised in
America all right well let's role play
this okay you come you're Otto student
oh no I'm here for my first day of work
I'm Otto struten oh hi Otto what's your
job here I was um hired to keep the
canisters that are filled with the
podcast wow tape huh
I mean in Europe he is legendary podcast
man and humor fellow he's so I'm very
excited everybody says oh Conan O'Brien
he is temper your expectations well when
you say well he's just gonna ridicule
you he's gonna belittle you make you
feel small and then make you high-five
him oh yeah sounds sounds fun so he's
includes me in the joke and then we all
laugh that's great no you're not
included in the joke you're the butt of
the joke yeah well the joke is joke who
cares if butt or or or one playing joke
Fun Fun For All yes no and he's gonna
make fun of your accent for sure oh well
it should I should learn English if I'm
to make it here so that is his way of
spurting me on to new heights and he's
gonna look fun of the way make fun of
the way you look too so why what is
wrong with that it's red hair yeah oh no
no I I don't care
to me just
just to Conan man
who is a known throughout the world as
best ever no no no never told you that
oh he rocks USA he's still no that's
weird that you said that my mom said the
exact same thing to him well she is
right to say it okay so I get to meet
him and then he would even high-five me
that's such an honor no boss is uh uh
your nose just fell on the table what's
what's happening oh I I'm having excuse
me let me get it and put back on oh yes
I had surgery in my country
um I live near a nuclear plant oh nose
fall off sometimes there we go it's back
on now yeah you're and your your hair
seems to be peeling up at this oh yes
yes again very strange side effect of
sausage I eat in a country according
best oh he's best so lucky that you all
worked for him and yet you [ __ ] and
moan and whine and complain about
working with great humor man do you know
what passive aggressive means it sounds
to me like if he's good at it then God
bless him no he he's best guy ever I
know this is incredible I think you are
spoiled Americans oh boohoo we don't
like working with great humor God is no
fun it be starshly
oh God
oh my God
sorry I just get so excited about Conan
all your costume elements fell off oh hi
guys it's me did I have you fooled
anyway nope well that was it was me all
along yeah I wish you guys liked me more
but I guess you don't